(exuberant jazz music)
(audience applauds)
- Nice to see you man.
- Nice to see you too.
- Oh my God, so nice meeting you.
- Thank you.
- Oh my good, that was badass.
- It was brutal.
Yeah, you know with enough rehearsal,
anybody could look like they can fight.
(audience laughing)
- [Derek] That was incredible.
Oh my gosh man!
You actually have three boys,
right?
- I do.
- [Derek] You have three boys at home.
So how does your wife feel
being the only woman in the house?
How's that?
- I think she's fine with it
cause she's not there very often.
- [Derek] Oh! (laughs)
- [Alan] So we moved to
Florida a little while ago,
right?
- [Derek] Okay.
- [Alan] So we're down in the South.
And not Miami, we're like deep south.
- [Derek] Right.
- Alabama-ish.
- Oh wow!
- And we are in like the
Bermuda triangle of Costco's.
We're two hours from every Costco.
And there's like one to the north.
So she has like her weekly Costco run,
and she'll be gone for days!
- Really? (laughs)
- And it's just me and the boys.
I'm just refereeing their fist fights.
- [Derek] Right.
- And we do the best we can.
And then we get fed when she comes home.
- [Derek] You actually posted a video,
I saw that of a plumbing emergency,
- [Alan] Oh yeah!
- Where some of the boys,
let's take a look at that right now.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- [Alan] Oh my gosh!
What the heck?
Oh my gosh!
Is there a poop in there right now?
- [Son] No.
- [Alan ] Did you pee?
- [Son] I didn't poop or pee.
I was just gonna go poop.
- [Alan] Oh my gosh!
- [Woman] Is guess
(indistinct) taking a shower?
- [Alan] Oh my gosh! Oh my gosh.
- [Son] All the pee!
- [Alan] Everybody grab a pair of shoes.
- [Derek] That is, oh my gosh!
- Yeah, we did save those shoes.
That's the important thing.
- [Derek] Did you guys figure
out which boy did it or?
- You know, I know that
my oldest now has a sign
on his bedroom door that says
'Warning Toxic Fumes' inside.
So I think,
I think it has something
to do with the him.
- [Derek] Right! So he's like,
- [Alan] Yes! There it is.
- [Derek] I may or may
not have done this father.
- Yeah.
I think those pipes are still
running to this day though.
That was a, that was we were
on like a farm in Toronto
where we shot Reacher.
- [Derek] Oh my gosh.
- And we told the landlord that
there was sewage everywhere.
And they were like,
"Oh, we'll get somebody out
there pretty soon there eh!."
And like three weeks later,
I'm still like mopping up the,
Anyway.
- Oh my gosh, man.
Now, so speaking of you're
in Toronto filming, right?
- [Alan] That's right.
- Filming Reacher.
- So it's, it's called Reacher.
And it's based off the
books, Jack Reacher,
and also the movies with Tom cruise in it.
Can you tell us a little
bit about the show?
- Sure. Yeah. So if you
haven't read the books,
Lee Child's brilliant Reacher series
is about a former military police officer.
He was a detective in the military,
and now he's retired, and
he just kind of wanders.
He's a hobo.
- Wow.
- [Alan] Nothing but a
toothbrush and a passport.
But you know with a
skillset like he's got,
he can't help but seek
justice wherever he goes.
So, you know, trouble seems to find him.
- [Derek] Trouble seems to find him.
I, I, so I actually,
I watched the first
episode the other night.
- Oh yeah!
What did you think?
- [Derek] I loved it man. I loved it.
First thing I said,
honestly I may or may not
have done a few pushups
and sit-ups as I was watching it.
- Okay. (laughs) Fair enough.
- [Derek] And my girlfriend walked in,
and she was like, "What are you doing?",
I was like, " Have you seen this guy?".
Oh my gosh!
So you bulked up for this role.
Quite a bit!
- [Alan] I did!
I did, yeah.
Yeah, I usually walk around at like 205.
(crowd applauds)
Yeah. Thanks guys.
Thanks.
- [Derek] Oh my gosh.
See you later ladies and
gentlemen, I'm out of here!
(Alan laughs)
Oh my God!
- Cause I want to be average.
I want to be average.
You know, I'm an actor,
I've gotta be able to play like the dad,
and doctor, and the superhero, you know?
Whatever comes by.
No but yeah, I put on 30 pounds, which is,
I don't know if you've ever done.
Have you ever put on 30 pounds?
- [Derek] No.
I don't even know if I
weighed 30 pounds honestly.
- It's (laughs) It's a
full-time job to eat enough,
- [Derek] Wow.
- To put on 30 pounds.
I had an assistant whose only
job was to bring me food.
It was like a conveyor belt
of smoothies and protein.
- [Derek] What does that
look like as far as like
how many times in a day?
- Hundreds!
- [Derek] Really?
- You know, but, you know,
you can get pretty clever with this.
I would order the crew,
like Popeye's chicken sandwiches,
cookies, just so I could get
the kind of calories I wanted.
It looks like a good will gesture.
- Wow.
(audience laughing)
- [Alan] You know?
Leave a dozen of those
in my trailer please.
Hashtag that.
- [Derek] Before we go,
you support something
called The Heart and,
The Heart and Armor Foundation.
- That's right.
- [Derek] Can you tell
a little bit about that?
- Yeah. So, you know,
we found each other at the right time.
I had like an early midlife crisis.
You know, I was depressed
and trying to find purpose and meaning.
My parents were, are both
veterans in the military.
- [Derek] Wow.
- You know, so I have a
heart for the service members
in the country
And you know, what people
don't realize is it's
the 1% serving the 99.
So not many of us can relate
to the kind of experiences
that they have, right?
But these are people who
need care and consideration.
And the Heart and Armor Foundation
is one that focuses on science.
So it's not sexy or glamorous,
but they do they do research that matters.
They'll study food
insecurity for veterans,
PTSD, women's health,
and reproductive health,
mental health in the armed services.
So, you know, it's really important work.
And I think, hopefully that science
sort of makes us way to
the rest of us, you know?
So we'll all benefit as we
normally do by their service.
So yeah, it's a good work.
Check them out at Heart
and Armor Foundation.
You know, they could
always use the support
to help fund the next study.
- [Derek] Absolutely
man. That's beautiful.
(audience applauds)
Thank you so much for being here Alan.
- Thank you!
- [Derek] You're the best man!